ils font partie de ces commerces de
première nécessité ne dites plus
essentiel donc qui ont toujours
travaillé pendant la pandémie les
boulangeries et les garages automobiles
un an plus tard situations bien
différentes pour ces deux professions
les batteries les pâtisseries pardon se
vendent comme des petits pains mais les
voitures roulent moins le reportage dans
l'agglomération tourangelle d'hélène
chapelet il y un an quasiment jour pour
jour on faisait la queue devant les
boulangeries pour faire des réserves de
pain dans ce commerce tourangeau la
première semaine du confinement
on a produit 2 sans baguette de plus
qu'en temps normal
un an plus tard les files d'attentes sur
le trottoir ont disparu si les ventes de
sandwiches et de snacking ou chuter à
cause du télétravail
les ventes plaisir elles ont bondi que
ce soit du côté des chocolats ou de la
pâtisserie
depuis un an les consommateurs ne se
privent plus à part que effectivement
l'année dernière on a on a produit
exactement la même chose et peut-être
voir un petit peu moins en appréhendant
justement cette période là et au final
on a vendu plus de plus de chocolat que
prévu pendant noël paraît les gens se
sont lâchés les conservateurs se sont
lâchés complètement et on a fait de
belles ventes aussi et puis le quotidien
c'est le petit éclair au chocolat
vraiment le petit gâteau plaisir et ça
on a bien vécu aussi autre commerce
considéré comme essentiel il ya un an
les garagistes ici à
saint-pierre-des-corps l'activité se
poursuivrait tant bien que mal sans
livraison de pièces détachées les
réparations devenait compliqué un an
plus tard le bilan est mitigé
deux employés sur 13 sont toujours au
chômage partiel faute d'activité
suffisante
les gens roulent mois
moins de déplacements beaucoup de
télétravail ce qui veut dire moins
d'accidents moins d'accidents moins de
travail c'est à peu près on va dire peu
près 1 9 % de notre chiffre en moins on
a sauvé les meubles
voilà mais bon là c'est ça repart bien
qu'il est bien reparti je pense que on
devrait faire quand une belle année 2001
à 21 depuis un an ses commerces et leurs
salariés n'ont cessé de s'adapter aux
contraintes engendrées par la crise
sanitaire dès samedi ils vont de nouveau
modifié leurs horaires de fermeture pour
tenir compte du nouveau couvre-feu à 19
heures